election day there will be additional  security at Clark County election  headquarters in North Las Vegas Metro is  monitoring security cameras and  additional security guards and police  will be on site Clark County Registrar  of Voters Joe Gloria tells us the county  is more prepared after Lessons Learned  From the last election cycle this in  part because of false claims of voter  fraud  those have been claims that have been  disproven there were several court cases  that went in in 2020 and none of them  are successful well the county gave a  media tour yesterday showing just where  those poll workers will be sorting and  verifying all the ballots